mission que font les enfants pendant les
vacances il ne se lance pas dans
l'informatique il dessine et même
d'ailleurs en dehors des vacances
témoin cette exposition de dessins
d'enfants à mâcon le thème en est le
cirque
il
autant duclair de la terre
autant des fusées
entendu claire de la terre
que ceux qui te feu
même au temps des fusées ils pensent à
noël les enfants de mâcon comme tous les
enfants à quelques jours du 25 décembre
ils sont mille six cent cinquante six à
avoir participé à ces dessins géants sur
le thème du cirque pour un concours
organisé par la municipalité de mâcon à
l'intention des écoles maternelles et
primaires de la ville
c'est la quatrième année qu'un tel
concours est organisé celui l'année
dernière avait connu un très gros succès
quatre mille personnes avaient visité
l'exposition à l'espace carnot mot revel
c'est le public qui est invité à voter
pour désigner les lauréats de ce
concours très consciencieusement chacun
des parents des petits dessinateur vient
voter pour le dessin et auquel a
participé son fils mais il n'y en ait
pas d'injustice à ce que les 70 dessins
terminé ex-aequo en prime les lauréats
auront droit à un spectacle de cirque le
public mâconnais pu visiter cette
exposition jusqu'au 19 janvier
s'il me fallait voter je désignerai ce
tableau là peut-être les enfants qu il
remarquer combien les animaux de cirque
sont tristes derrière leurs barreaux ils
ont en tout cas imaginer pour ce dessin
d'inverser les rôles
et ils ont placé le lion en position de
dompteur ça s'intitule chacun son tour
et c'est la revanche de l'animal sur
l'homme
c'est bien vu et ses charmes en votant
duclair
demont les verrez de là